(playful music)
♪ It must be love ♪
- {Interviewer] Wow,
you're looking cozy today.
- Yeah well I like to
hang out in here sometimes
because it's warmer than the cabinet.
- [Interviewer] So where's
your partner, Butter?
- Oh, we're not always together.
I think Butter went to a
potluck or a cookie party.
Is that a thing?
I'll just text and ask.
Oh, they haven't texted back yet.
Maybe Butter's been in the bathroom.
- [Interviewer] For an hour?
- Well, Butter's lactose intolerant.
It's very common in Ashkenazi Jews,
So yeah, it could be hours
before we see them again.
- [Interviewer] Yeah but
don't people usually take
their phones with them if they're gonna be
in the bathroom for a long time?
(sad music)
- This is cool.
I'm cool.
♪Independent Toasty coming through. ♪
(continues singing to themself)
- Toast, good thing you called your BFF,
because this is fucked up.
It's been two hours.
If my boo, (pronounces with
heavy accent) Machalanan
doesn't text me back within five,
he's toast.
Sorry.
You know what I mean.
- A really derogatory term.
- I'm sorry.
- Prefer you didn't.
It's award.
Okay, what if Butter's hurt or something?
Or like, Butter fell
and is in some sewer somewhere?
I mean, Butter's just so slippery.
What if Butter's with someone else?
Like, some Pop tart
or muffin
or bagel?
- OMG!
Butter was tagged on Insta at the mall
10 minutes ago.
- What?!
Is that a dog?
Wait, don't dogs eat butter?
Don't dogs eat butter?!
Aaaaaah!
- Peanut butter, not butter.
Get a hold of yourself.
- (moans)
- Don't do it, don't text them.
- I just want one more little,
little text.
- No!
Like, a small emoji, an easygoing emoji.
Like a penguin.
It's super casual.
It'll be super chill.
- You can't text them anymore.
- I'm not letting you.
- Just one more little text.
- No, no!
- Let me text!
- [Interviewer] What's all this?
- Oh, I'm breaking up with Butter.
- [Interviewer] Wait, its
only been three hours.
Don't you think you two
might be overreacting?
- No, I don't think I'm overreacting.
- How dare you belittle my BFF's feelings
in their time of need.
(Toast sobbing)
It's okay.
Don't cry, it's okay.
(shushes as Toast whimpers)
- Checking all Butter's
social media accounts.
(keyboard clacking)
I'm checking Twitter,
I'm checking #Buttersdead
Buttersf(bleep)cking dead.
Oh my God, hashtag Butter's dead.
I haven't seen anything yet.
But if Butter's not dead,
(whispers ominously) he will be soon.
(Cupcake and Toast
tweaking out to rock music)
- [Interviewer] Has Butter
texted you back yet?
- No.
Butter's definitely 100% dead.
- Sad, sorry test.
- [Interviewer] Wait, dead?
That seems like a pretty crazy conclusion.
- I guess I'll just have to get used to
being a butter less toast. (moans)
(Cupcake and Toast completely
freaking out to rock music)
- I can't believe Butter is
dead in a ditch somewhere.
Probably happy in a raccoon,
or Paula Deen.
They're running rampant
- [Cupcake] Hey Toasties, hang in there.
I'll call and check on you in the morning.
(kiss)
(melodramatic piano music)
- Hey Babe!
Sorry I'm so late,
My phone died.
- Oh! You were not here?
I didn't even f(bleep)cking notice.
- [Butter] Hey Toast, was there
an Amber Alert about myself?
♪ It must be love ♪
♪ It seems that only I can see ♪
♪ The love she has for me ♪